[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au gros nounours
j'ai bien l'impression que ce soir
pimprenelle et nicolas attendent avec
beaucoup d'impatience
vous croyez pas trop que je suis au les
chers petits loges du c'est aujourd'hui
la fête des mamans mon le seul e up
jboss hop hop hop hop hop hop
bonne fête à toutes les mamans bon sort
le petit on en jargon nemours tu sais
bourse je viens d'aller à la campagne
avec papa et maman et on a fait une
grosse et on a cueilli des fleurs on est
donné à maman car c'est la fête des
mamans aujourd'hui le selon toi ne nous
as donné ta maman à ta maman au luc une
belle le et je lui envoyais eu un gros
coup de main papin
et les six pour mon ma vie mais il a
fait tout un cadeau à ma main et tout le
monde lambres si elle était très
contente et elle a pleuré c'est très
bien ça en devient il faut toujours
beaucoup lu qu'elle a toi ta maman je
suis un bon long le but i ou du dos oui
et manosque aulas qui s'est nourri notre
âme à main chaque soir quand on est
couché et qu'on dort sagement elle vient
nous voir dans notre lit avec papa et
nous en broche à pas et vient pas fin
mai mamaev elle vient toujours oui même
quand on a été méchant de nous qui
croient que les mamans elles sont comme
ça mais oui tous les soirs pour les
petits-enfants d'or elles viennent
fermer les volets bond et leurs lots
redonner un bout
[Musique]
ma maman à moi le faisait eh bien nous
on l aime beaucoup notre moment et on
aimera toujours moi aussi le petit
bonjour la banane hausse à nos mains
bonne nuit nicolas elle pourrait pas pr
neil bonne fête à toutes les mamans
bonne maman à bois
bonne nuit les enfants continuer à être
bien sage et à toujours être très gentil
avec votre maman oui auto allons en
route hier nounours
bonne nuit à demain embrasse bien fort
votre maman et de boer
[Musique]